ich weiß es gibt dinge die sie mir nicht
sagen dürfen
aber ich weiß auch hier gibt es eine
story von der jeder hören wird kamikaze
spotlight erzählt von einem enthüllungs
skandal den eine gruppe von reportern
des boston globe
in der zeit der jahrtausendwende
aufgedeckt haben und zwar geht es um den
missbrauchsskandal in der katholischen
kirche ein und fachliches elend dass ich
dort ausbreitet in diesem fonds
sie sagen uns wenn wir eine story über
50 pädophile priester in boston breiter
dann würden wir nur dasselbe geschrei
auslösen über porta das verursacht zwar
krach ändert die dinge allerdings kein
bisschen
das ganze ist völlig unaufgeregt
inszeniert von thermografie mit einem
großartigen team von schauspielern
rachel mcadams mai kapitän john terry
welche songs schreiben denn eine
schreiben die auf jeden fall die
kontrollieren alles es ist nicht nur
boston es passiert den ganzen land auf
der ganzen welt
das erstaunlich als dass ein so großer
skandal eine so wirklich weltumspannende
geschichte die die katholische kirche
amerikas in ihre vermutlich schwerste
krise der neuzeit gestürzt hat mit einer
solchen ruhe und ohne jedwede
kraftmeierei die im kino ja im
augenblick urständ feiert gefilmt worden
das wunderbare an diesem film ist das
eher recherchearbeit und nicht zum
heldentum aufmotzt sondern als das zeigt
was es ist zähe arbeit diese dinge die
eigentlich langweilig sind könnte man
sagen aber so inszeniert dass sich eine
spannung aufbaut sagen sie mir dass die
kirche manipulieren nur damit diese
leute nicht angeklagt werden zeigen sie
mir dass dieselben priester wieder und
wieder in gemeinden geschickt werden
zeigen sie mir dass das ganze system hat
und von oben gesteuert wird
es geht um was es geht um sehr viel es
geht um eine institution die den glauben
von menschen verwaltet und diese
menschen auf gröbste enttäuscht hinters
licht führt und es geht gleichzeitig
aber um diese menschen die in ihrem
glauben festhalten
trotzdem und der film versucht gar nicht
den leuten jetzt ihren glauben
auszureden
wir gehen gegen diese institution vor
weil sie verbrecherisch und
verantwortlich grausam gehandelt hat
ohne dadurch die religion selber an den
pranger zu stellen
sie wussten es und haben es laufen
lassen mit kindern
okay das hättest du sein können oder ich
jeder von uns hätte es sein können
wir müssen diese dreckschwein festnageln
wir müssen den leuten zeigen dass
niemand mit so was durchkommen kann kein
priester kein kardinal und kein
verdammter papst mit der festen griff
hatte vorher schon hinweise auf diesen
skandal denen er nicht nachgegangen ist
was die große schuld ist auch als ein
neuer chefredakteur der nicht in der
katholischen kirche betet ist mich ein
jude und der nimmt den kampf auf
sie waren die katholische kirche
verklagen
wir stellen nur einen antrag aber für
mich ist bud light einer der filme der
saison
ich hoffe sehr dass er bei den oscars wo
er bei denen er für viele auszeichnungen
nominiert das hat auch in den letzten
monaten überall ziemlich abgeräumt dass
er auch bei den oscars nicht ganz leer
ausgeht
so entsteht so was oder was meinen sie
irgendeiner übt druck auf einen anderen
haus und eine ganze stadt zieht einfach
weg